Ridley Scott's alien is a sci-fi horror
classic a crazy cocktail of influences
that somehow manages to be more
frightening than the sum of its parts
everybody who worked on it had their own
idea of what alien would be about
perhaps that's why scholars sci-fi nerds
and film critics alike continue to
discover creepy unexplored channels
within this terrifying masterpiece so
now let's take a look at the story
behind alien Dark Star if you could
trace the origin of alien back to one
single point it would have to be Dan
O'Bannon 1974 sci-fi comedy Doug star
while attending USC O'Bannon made a
seven-minute horror suspense short film
called bloodbath the project caught the
attention of a young John Carpenter also
a student and the two sets out to make a
science fiction movie for John
Carpenter's master's thesis they called
their finished movie dad star and it
wasn't very good it did have an alien in
it but unfortunately that alien with a
beach ball with feet
according to O'Bannon instead of the
most impressive student film ever made
we had the least impressive professional
film ever made but to that crappy film
gave birth to a legend several years
down the line I decided to do Dark Star
as a horror movie instead of a comedy
and that was the germ of alien not many
people saw Dark Star but future alien
director Ridley Scott did
along with visionary Chilean French
filmmaker Alejandro Jodorowsky and it
left a lasting impression June
connections
Jodorowsky was so impressed with Dark
Star that he hired O'Bannon to help him
adapt Frank Herbert's space opera June
for the big screen the project
ultimately tanked but alien was one of
the many successful projects that rose
from the ashes of jodorowsky ill-fated
attempt O'Bannon moved to Paris to work
on June which is where he met artist
Christopher fuss it laid to do design
work for alien as well as future alien
designer HR Giger Jodorowsky's
philosophy of art design also heavily
influenced O'Bannon's work on alien he
would find his quote spiritual warriors
and then put them together in one big
room to work out a movie structure later
O'Bannon would use the same strategy to
brainstorm about alien bringing together
fuss Gieger and cartoonists Mobius and
Ron Cobb to hash out the designs their
little sci-fi horror project script
struggles ultimately Brandywine
productions agreed to produce the film
for 20th Century Fox with Ridley Scott
in the director's chair
but the Nostromo still had some
turbulence ahead according to O'Bannon
producers a David giler
and Walter hell wanted to completely
redo his script so that's exactly what
they did
according to gala he and Hill added the
feminist elements everyone is talking
about we gave the characters texture
functions in O'Bannon Strauss they were
totally different military types or men
we changed all the dialogue every word
of it O'Bannon the original screenplay
featured a xenomorph and the wrecked
ship and that's about where the
similarities for the finished
and Tails and Gaia's rewrites added
Ripley and Dallas and the rest of the
gang not to mention the whole vast
corporate conspiracy subplot and the
entire concepts for human looking
Androids an idea that was already an
alien cornerstone by the first sequel
[Music]
thank you but bizarrely some drafts also
had a time travel based plot line
featuring Jack the Ripper Hercules and
Genghis Khan like a Magic Treehouse book
with murderous chester birthing aliens
then there's the alien fat against all
odds Scotland has teams somehow made
despite all the confusion as artists
Christopher Foss splitted the den of
geek poor old Dan O'Bannon the bloke
whose concept it was just got absolutely
shafted I kind of got the impression
that Ridley was quietly going his own
way trying to get on with it and get it
done
shipshape the Nostromo the dark
claustrophobic spaceship where all the
alien action takes place is practically
another character in the movie and Chris
fuss and Ron Cobb were essential to the
creation of the vessel but the final
result didn't come right away the team
worked on the design for five whole
months pretty much the whole time the
producers were trying to find a director
for the movie and some of those designs
got weird first had endless spaceship
designs
suggesting submarines at diesel
locomotives Mayan interceptors
Mississippi riverboats and a jumbo space
arks but in the end they were simply too
outlandish for the producers to get on
board the Nostromo's final design that
came from one of Ron Cobbs simple of
sketches and even then Ridley Scott made
the ships modeler get rid of Cobbs
original yellow color scheme in favor of
the flat grader made it into the film
casting chaos before Sigourney Weaver
got the part of Ripley none other than
Meryl Streep was on the short list of
candidates to be offered the role Streep
is of course ridiculously talented and
alien probably would have been just fine
with her in the lead role but fate
intervened in 1978 Streep's romantic
partner actor John Cazale passed away
and nobody felt comfortable
interrupting her morning to make the
offer as it turns out
Ripley wasn't even sigourney weaver's
first choice she said in an interview
actually the part I wanted to play was
Lambert Veronica Cartwright part in the
first script I read lumber just cracked
jokes the whole time that's the
character I could identify with and
while Weaver wanted the path of Lambert
Veronica Carter I was dead set on
playing Ripley it was only just before
shooting began that scraps right was
told their roles have been switched
obviously the decisions all worked out
from the end but it's interesting to
consider how close we were to getting a
completely different movie silly scenes
Wibbly Scott works hard to preserve the
lessons more aesthetic that's made alien
so terrifying and that meant cutting a
lot of scenes from the final film some
of the biggest cuts were made because
they looked kind of stupid
for example Lambert's death is haunting
because most of it is implied and
off-screen the camera cuts away just
before the alien get sir so we don't
actually see what happens but her death
was filmed it just looked way too cheesy
by the same token bretch death in the
final film is terrifying but the
extended cut of that scene is borderline
absurd
I'm not come over to Academical legacy
for a sci-fi horror creature feature
alien gets a surprising amount of love
in the academic world case in points
June 2017 saw the publication of a book
called alien and philosophy a collection
of essays on all things alien it's heavy
stuff but it just goes to show there's
more to the xenomorph or the facehugger
a chest burster and a man in a crocodile
suit if the grotesque imagery
state-of-the-art special-effects and a
storage production aren't enough to
build a compelling film theory thesis
that maybe or those Freudian themes will
do the trick
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]